i talked to uh a guy named charles
hoskinson
he mentioned that he's collaborating
with you
he's an interesting guy he sends me
papers on uh speaking of automated
theorem proving a lot he's exceptionally
well read on that area as well so what's
the nature of your collaboration with
him he's the creator of cardano what's
the nature of the color collaboration
between
cardano and the whole space of
blockchain and wolf thermal from alpha
or from blockchain all that kind of
stuff
well okay we're segueing to a
slightly different world but but um so
although not completely unconnected
right the whole thing is somehow
connected i know i mean
you know the strange thing in my life is
i've sort of alternated between doing
basic science and doing technology about
five times in my life so far and the
thing that's just crazy about it is you
know every time i do one of these
alternations i think there's not going
to be a way back to the other thing and
like i thought for this physics project
i thought you know we're doing
fundamental theory of physics maybe
it'll have an application in 200 years
but now i've realized
actually this multi-computation idea is
is applicable here and now it's and in
fact it's also giving us this way uh
i'll just mention one other thing and
then to talk about blockchain um the um
the question of um uh actually that
relates to several different things but
but um one of the things about about
okay so
our wolfram language which is
our attempt to kind of represent
everything in the world computationally
and it's the thing i kind of started
building 40 years ago in the form of
actual wolfram language 35 years ago
it's kind of this idea of can we can we
express things about the world in
computational terms and you know we've
come a long way in being able to do that
or from alpha is kind of the consumer
version of that where you're just using
natural language as input the um and it
turns it into our symbolic language and
that's you know the symbolic language
world from language is what people use
and have been using for the last 33
years actually mathematica which is its
first instantiation will be one third of
a century old in uh in october um and um
that
it's it's kind of interesting what do
you mean third of a centuries i mean 33
or 30. what are we
in the third
33 in the third um so
but i've never heard of anyone
celebrating that anniversary but i like
it i know a third of a century though
it's it's like cannot get many many
slices of a century that are interesting
yeah but but you know i think that the
the thing that's really striking about
that is that means um you know including
the whole sort of technology stack are
built around that's about 40 years old
and that means it's a significant
fraction of the total age of the
computer industry um and it's i mean i
think it's cool that we can still run
you know mathematica version one
programs today and so on and and we've
sort of maintained compatibility and
we've been just building this big tower
all those years of just more and more
and more computational capabilities it's
sort of interesting we just made this
this picture um of kind of the different
kind of threads of
of of computational content of you know
mathematical content and
and you know
all sorts of things with you know data
and graphs and whatever else and what
you see in this picture is about the
first 10 years it's kind of like it's
just a few threads
and then then about
maybe 15 20 years ago it kind of
explodes in this whole collection
different threads of all these different
capabilities that are now part of
warfarin language and representing
different things in the world but the
thing that was super lucky in some sense
is it's all based on one idea it's all
based on the idea of symbolic
expressions and transformation rules for
symbolic expressions which was kind of
what i originally put into this snp
system back in 1979 that was a
predecessor of the whole world from
language stack
so that idea
was an idea that i got
from sort of trying to understand
mathematical logic and so on it was my
attempt to kind of make a general human
comprehensible model of computation of
just everything is a symbolic expression
and all you do is transform symbolic
expressions and you know in in
retrospect i was very lucky that i
understood as little as i understood
then because had i understood more i
would have been completely freaked out
about all the different ways that that
kind of model can can fail because what
do you do when you have a a a symbolic
expression you make transformations for
symbolic expressions well for example
one question is there may be many
transformations that could be made in a
very multi-computational kind of way but
what we're doing is picking we're using
the first transformation that applies
and we keep doing that until we reach a
fixed point and that's the result and
that's kind of a very
it's kind of a way of of sort of sliding
around the edge of multi-computation
and back when i was working on smp and
things i actually thought about these
questions about about how you know how
what determines the this kind of
evaluation path so for example you know
you work out fibonacci you know
fibonacci is a recursive thing f of n is
f of n minus one plus f of minus two and
you get this whole tree of recursion
right and there's the question of how do
you evaluate that tree of recursion do
you do it sort of depth first where you
go all the way down one side do you do
it breadth first where you're kind of
collecting the terms together where you
know that you know f of eight plus f of
seven f of seven plus f of six you can
collect the f of sevens and so on these
are um you know i didn't realize that at
the time it's kind of funny i was
working on on gauge field theories back
in 1979 i was also working on the
evaluation model
in smp under the same problem but it
took me 40 more years to realize that
and this question about how you do this
sort of evaluation front that's a
question of reference frames it's a
question of of kind of the um the story
of i mean that that's that is basically
this question of in what order is the
universe evaluated
and that and so what you realize is
there's this whole sort of world of
different kinds of computation that you
can do sort of multi-computationally and
that's a that's an interesting thing it
has a lot of implications for
distributed computing and so on
it also has a potential implication for
blockchain which we haven't fully worked
out which is um and this is not what
we're doing with cardano but but this is
a different thing um the um
this is something where uh one of the
questions is um when you have
in a sense blockchain is a deeply
sequentialized story of time
because in blockchain there's just one
copy of the of the ledger and you're
saying this is what happened you know
time has progressed in this way and
they're little things around the edge as
as you try and reach consensus and so on
and and uh you know actually we just
recently we've had this little
conference we organized about the the
theory of distributed consensus because
i realized that a bunch of interesting
things that some of our science can tell
one about that but that's a different
let's let's not go down that that part
yeah but distributed consensus that
still has a sequential there's like
there's still sequentiality so don't
don't tell me you're thinking through
like how to apply multi-computation to
uh blockchain yes
and so so that becomes a story of you
know instead of transactions all having
to settle in one ledger it's like a
story of all these different ledgers and
they all have to have some ultimate
consistency which is what causal and
variance would give one but it can take
a while and the it can take a while as
kind of like quantum mechanics so it's
kind of what's happening is that these
different paths of history that
correspond to you know in one part of
history you got paid this amount in
another part of history you got paid
this amount in the end the universe will
always become consistent now now the way
it will it works is
okay it's a little bit more complicated
than that what happens is the way space
is knitted together in our theory of
physics is through all these events and
the the the idea is that the way that
economic space is knitted together is
between is there these autonomous events
that essentially knit together economic
space so there are all these threads of
transactions that are happening and the
question is can they be made consistent
are there is there something forcing
them to be sort of a consistent fabric
of economic reality and sort of what
this has led me to is trying to realize
how does economics fundamentally work
and you know what is economics and uh
you know what what are the atoms of
economics right so to speak and so what
i've kind of realized is that that sort
of the
perhaps i don't even know if this is
right yet there's sort of events in
economics of transactions there are
states of agents that are kind of the
atoms of economics
and then transactions are kind of agents
transact and some
transact in some way and that's an event
and then the question is how do you knit
together sort of economic space from
that what is there an economic space
well all these transactions there's a
whole complicated collection of possible
transactions but one thing that's true
about economics is we tend to have the
notion of a definite value for things
we could imagine
that you know you buy
a cookie
from somebody and
they want to get a movie ticket
and there is some way that ai bots could
make some path
from the cookie to the movie ticket by
all these different trans intermediate
transactions
but in fact
we have an approximation to that which
is we say they each have a dollar value
and we have this kind of numeric concept
of there's just a way of kind of of of
taking this whole complicated space of
transactions and parsing it in something
which is a kind of a simplified thing
that is kind of like our parsing of
physical space
and so my my guess is that the uh yet
again i mean it's crazy that all these
things are so connected this is another
multi-computation story another story of
where what's happening is that the
economic consciousness the economic
observer is not going to deal with all
of those are different microscopic
transactions they're just going to parse
the whole thing by saying there's this
value it's a number and that's that's
their understanding of their summary of
this economic network and there will be
all kinds of things like there are all
kinds of arbitrage opportunities which
are kind of like the quantum effects in
this whole thing and um that's uh you
know and places where there's where
there's sort of different paths that can
be followed and and so on and there's so
the question is can one make a sort of
global theory of economics and then my
test case is again what is time dilation
in economics
and and i know for you know if you
imagine a very agricultural economics
where people are growing lettuces and
fields and things like this and you ask
questions about well if you're
transporting lettuces to different
places you know what is the value of the
lettuces after you have to transport
them versus if you're just sitting in
one place and selling them you can kind
of get a little bit of an analogy there
but i think there's a there's a better
and more complete analogy and that's the
question of is there a theory like
general relativity that is a global
theory of economics and is it about
something we care about it could be that
there is a global theory but it's about
a feature of economic reality that isn't
important to us now another part of the
story is can one use those ideas to make
essentially a distributed blockchain a
distributed generalization of blockchain
kind of the quantum analog of money so
to speak where where you have for
example you can have uncertainty
relations where you're saying you know
well if i if i insist on knowing my bank
account right now there'll be some
uncertainty if i'm prepared to wait a
while then it'll be much more certain um
and so there's you know is there a way
of using and so we've made a bunch of
prototypes of this
um which i'm not yet happy with because
what i realized is to really understand
these prototypes actually have to have a
foundational theory of economics and so
that's kind of a
you know it may be that we could deploy
one of these prototypes as a practical
system but i think it's really going to
be much better if we actually have an
understanding of how this plugs into
kind of the economics that means like a
fundamental theory of transactions
between
entities well that's that's what you
mean by economics yes i think so but i
mean you know how how there emerge sort
of laws of economics i don't even know
and i've been asking friends of mine who
are who are economists and things what
is economics you know is it an axiomatic
theory is it a theory that is a kind of
a qualitative description theory is it
you know what kind of a theory is it is
it a theory you know what kind of
thinking it's like like in in biology
and evolutionary biology for example
there's a certain there's a certain
pattern of thinking that goes on in
evolutionary biology where if you're a
you know a good evolutionary biologist
somebody says that creature has a weird
horn and they'll say well that's because
this and this and this and the selection
of this kind and that kind and that's
the story and it's not a mathematical
story it's a story of a different type
of thinking about these things by the
way
evolution of biology is yet another
place where it looks like this
multi-computational idea can be applied
and that's uh where where maybe
speciation is related to things like
event horizons and there's a whole whole
other kind of world of that but because
it seems like this kind of model can be
applicable in so many aspects like at
the different levels
of understanding of uh our reality so it
could be the biology of the chemistry at
the physics level
right the economics and you could
potentially the thing is
it's like
okay sure at all these levels it might
rhyme it might make sense as a model the
question is can you make useful
predictions as one of these levels
that's that's right and that's that's
really a question of
you know it's a weird situation because
it's a situation where the model
probably has definite consequences the
question is are they consequences we
care about yeah and and that's some uh
you know and so
so and in the case of in the economic
case
the um
uh
where
um so you know the one one thing is this
this idea of using kind of physics-like
notions
to construct a kind of distributed
analog blockchain okay the much more
pragmatic thing is that is a different
direction and it has to do with this
computational language that we built to
describe the world that knows about you
know different kinds of cookies and
knows about different cities and knows
about how to compute all these kinds of
things
one of the things that is of interest is
if you want to run the world
you need you know with with with
contracts and laws and rules and so on
there are rules at a human level and
there are kind of um things like
and so this this gets one into the idea
of computational contracts you know
right now when we write a contract it's
a piece of legalese it's you know it's
just written in english and it's not
something that's automatically
analyzable executable whatever else it's
just english you know back in uh
gottfried leibniz back in you know 1680
or whatever was like um i'm gonna you
know figure out how to use logic to
decide legal cases and so on and he had
kind of this idea of let's make a
computational language for the huma the
human law
um forget about modeling nature forgot
about natural laws what about human law
can we make kind of a computational
representation of that well i think
finally we're close to being able to do
that and one of the projects that i hope
to get to as soon as the there's a
little bit of slowing down of some of
this cambrian explosion that's happening
as a project i've been meaning to really
do for a long time which is what i'm
calling a symbolic discourse language
it's is just finishing the job of being
able to represent everything like the
conversation we're having in
computational terms and one of the use
cases for that as computational
contracts another use case is something
like the the constitution that says what
the ai's what we want the ais to do so
but this is useful so you're saying uh
so these are like you're saying
computational contracts but smart
contracts this is what's in the domain
of cryptocurrencies known as smart
contracts and so the the language you've
developed this symbolic
or seek to further develop symbolic
discourse language enables you to uh
write a contract and right so right a
contract that richly represents
some aspect of the world yeah but so so
i mean smart contracts tend to be right
now mostly about things happening on the
blockchain yes and sometimes they have
oracles in fact our wolfram alpha api is
that is the main thing people use to get
information about the real world so to
speak yeah within smart contracts so
well from alpha as it stands is a really
good oracle yes whoever wants to use it
that's perhaps where the relationship
with cardano is
how we started getting involved with
blockchains is we realized people were
using you know wolfman alpha as the
oracle for smart contract so to speak
and so that got us interested in
blockchains in general and what was
ended up happening is well from language
is with its symbolic representation of
things is really very good at
representing
things like blockchains and so i think
we now have them we don't really know
all the comparisons but we now have a
really nice environment within wolverine
language for dealing with the sort of uh
you know for representing what happens
in blockchains for analyzing what
happens in blockchains we have a whole
effort in blockchain analytics
um and uh you know we've sort of
published some samples of how that works
but but it's you know because our
technology stack well from language and
mathematica are very widely used in the
quant finance world there's a there's a
sort of immediate uh sort of um uh
co-evolution there of of sort of the
quant finance kind of thing and
blockchain analytics and that's um so so
it's kind of the representation of
blockchain in computational language
then ultimately it's kind of like how do
you run the world with code that is how
do you write sort of all these things
which are right now regulations and laws
and contracts and things in
computational language and kind of the
the ultimate vision is that sort of
something happens in the world and then
there's this giant domino effect of all
these computational contracts that
trigger based on the thing that happened
and there's a there's a whole story to
that and of course you know i i like to
always pay attention to the latest
things that are going on and i i really
i kind of like blockchain because it's a
it's a it's another rethinking of kind
of computation it's kind of like you
know cloud computing was a little bit of
that of sort of persistent
um kind of
computational resources and so on and uh
you know this multi-computation is a big
rethinking of kind of what it means to
compute blockchain is another bit of
rethinking of what it means to compute
the idea that you lodge kind of these
autonomous lumps of computation out
there in the blockchain world and and
one of the things that um just sort of
uh for fun so to speak is we've been
doing a bit of stuff with nfts and we
just did some nfts on gardano and we'll
be doing some more and uh you know we
did some cellular automaton nfts on
kadana
like quite a bit um and you know one of
the things i've realized about about
nfts is that there's kind of this notion
and we're really working on this you
know i like recording stuff you know one
of the things that's come out of of kind
of my science i suppose is this this
history matters type type story of you
know it's not just the current state
it's the history that matters and i've
kind of i don't think this is uh
actually realizing maybe it's not
coincidental that i'm sort of the human
who's recorded more about themselves
than anybody else and then i end up with
these science results that say history
matters which was not those those things
i didn't think those were connected but
but they're at least correlated yes yeah
right so
you know this question about sort of
recording what has happened and and
having sort of a permanent record of
things one of the things that's kind of
interesting there is you know you put up
a website and it's got a bunch of stuff
on it but you know you have to keep
paying the hosting fees or the things
going to go away
but one of the things about blockchain
is kind of interesting is if you put
something on a blockchain and you pay
you know your commission to get that
thing you know put on you know mind put
on the blockchain then then in a sense
everybody who comes after you
is you know they are motivated to keep
your thing alive because that's what
keeps the consistency of the blockchain
so in a sense with sort of the nft world
it's kind of like if you want to have
something permanent well at least for
the life of the blockchain but but even
if the blockchain goes out of
circulation so to speak there's going to
be enough value in that whole collection
of transactions that people are going to
archive the thing but that means that
you know pay once
and you're kind of you're lodged in the
blockchain forever and so we've been
kind of playing around with um sort of a
hobby thing of of mine of of thinking
about sort of the nfts
and how you um and sort of the consumer
idea of kind of the it's the it's the
anti you know it's the opposite of the
snapchat view of the world so there's a
permanence to it this heavily
incentivized
and uh
thereby you can have a
permanence of history right and that's
that's that's kind of the um now you
know so that's so that's one of the
things we've been doing with cardano and
it's kind of fun i think that that um i
mean this whole question about you know
you mentioned automated theorem proving
and blockchains and so on and as i've
thought about this kind of
physics-inspired distributed blockchain
obviously
they're the sort of the proof that it
works that they're no double spends
there's no whatever else
that proof becomes a very formal kind of
almost a matter of physics so to speak
um and uh you know it's been it's been
an interesting thing for the for the
practical blockchains to do kind of
actual automated theorem proving and i
don't think anybody's really managed it
in an interesting case yet it's a thing
that people you know aspire to but i
think it's a challenging thing because
basically the point is one of the one of
the things about proving correctness of
something is well you know people say
i've got this program and i'm going to
prove it's correct it's like what does
that mean you have to say what correct
means i mean it's it's kind of like then
you have to have another language and
people were very confused back in past
decades of you know oh we're going to
prove the correctness by representing
the program in another language which we
also don't know whether it's correct and
you know often by correctness we just
mean it can't crash or it can't scribble
on memory but but the thing is that
there's this complicated trade-off
because as soon as there's as soon as
you're really using computation you have
computational irreducibility you have
undecidability if you want to use
computation seriously you have to kind
of let go of the idea that you're going
to be able to box it in and say we're
going to have just this happen and not
anything else i mean this is a this is
an old fact i mean girdle's theorem
tries to say you know piano arithmetic
the axioms of arithmetic can you box in
the integers and say these axioms give
just the integers and nothing but the
integers godel's theorem showed that
wasn't the case there's a you know you
can have all these wild weird things
that are obey the piano axioms but
aren't integers and there's this kind of
infinite hierarchy of additional axioms
you would have to add and it's kind of
the same thing you you don't get to you
know if you want to say i want to know
what happens you're boxing yourself in
and there's a limit to what can happen
so to speak so it's a it's a complicated
trade-off and it's a it's a it's a big
trade-off for ai so to speak it's kind
of like do you want to let computation
actually do what it can do or do you
want to say no it's very very boxed in
to the point where we can understand
every step and that's a that's kind of a
thing that that that becomes difficult
to do but that that's some i mean in in
general
i would say one of the things that's
kind of complicated in my
uh sort of life and the whole sort of
story of computational language and all
this technology and science and so on i
mean i i kind of in in the flow of one's
life it's sort of interesting to see how
these things play out because i you know
i've kind of concluded that i'm in the
business of making kind of artifacts
from the future
which means you know they're things that
i've done i don't know this physics
project i don't know whether anybody
would have gotten to it for 50 years you
know the fact that mathematica is a
third of a century old and i know that a
bunch of the core ideas are not well
absorbed i mean that is people finally
got this idea that i thought was a
triviality of notebooks that was 25
years
and um you know some of these core ideas
about symbolic computation and so on are
not are not absorbed i mean people
people use them every day in wolfram
language and you know do all kinds of
cool things with them but if you say
what is the fundamental intellectual
point here it's it's not well absorbed
and it's it's something where you kind
of realize that you're you're sort of
building things and i i kind of made
this this thing about you know we're
building artifacts from the future so to
speak and i mentioned that it's our uh
we have a a a conference ever it's
coming up actually in a couple of weeks
the annual technology conference
uh where we talk about all the all the
things we're doing um and uh you know so
i was talking about it last year about
you know we're making artifacts from the
future and i was kind of like i had some
some version of that that was kind of a
dark and frustrated thing of like you
know i'm building things which nobody's
going to care about until long after i'm
dead so to speak but um but but then i i
realized you know people
were sort of telling me afterwards you
know that's exactly how you know we're
using wolfram language in some
particular setting in you know some
computational x field or some
organization or whatever and it's like
people are saying oh you know what did
you manage to do you know well we know
that in principle it will be possible to
do that but we didn't know that was
possible now
and it's kind of like that's the that's
sort of the business we're in and in a
sense with some of these ideas in
science um you know i feel a little bit
the same way that there are some of
these things where you know some some
things like for example this whole idea
well so so to to relate to another sort
of piece of history and the future one
of you know i mentioned we mentioned at
the beginning kind of complexity as this
thing that i was interested in back 40
years ago and so on where does
complexity come from well i think we
kind of nailed that the answer is in the
computational universe even simple
programs make it and that's kind of the
secret that nature has that allows you
to make it so so that's kind of the um
uh that that's that part but the bigger
picture there was this idea of this kind
of computational paradigm the idea that
you could go beyond mathematical
equations which have been sort of the
primary modeling medium for 300 years
and so it was like look it is inexorably
the case that people will use programs
rather than just equations and you know
i was saying that in the 1980s and
people were you know i published my big
book new kind of science that'll be 20
years ago uh next year so in 2002 and
people are saying oh no this can't
possibly be true you know we know for
300 years we've been doing all this
stuff right
to be fair
i now realize on a little bit more
analysis of what people actually said in
pretty much every field other than
physics people said oh these are new
models that's pretty interesting in
physics people were like we've got our
physics models we're very happy with
them yeah in physics there's more
resistance because of the attachment and
the power of the equations right the
idea that programs might be the right
way to approach
right uh this field was there's some
resistance and like you're saying
it takes time for somebody who likes the
idea of time dilation and all these
applications i thought you would
understand this yeah right but but you
know and computational introduceability
yes exactly but but i mean it is really
interesting that just 20 years
a span of 20 years it's gone from you
know pitchforks and horror
to
yeah we get it and um you know it's
helped that we've you know in our
current
effort in fundamental physics we've
gotten a lot further and we've managed
to
put a lot of puzzle pieces together that
that makes sense but the thing that i've
been thinking about recently is this
field of complexity so i i've kind of
was a sort of a field builder back in
the 1980s i was kind of like okay you
know can we uh you know i i'd understood
this point that there was this sort of
fundamental phenomenon of complexity and
showed up in lots of places and i was
like this is an interesting sort of
field of science and i was uh recently
was reminded i was at this the very
first sort of get-together of what
became the santa fe institute and i was
like in fact there's even an audio
recording of me sort of saying people
have been talking about oh what should
this play you know outfit do and i was
saying well there is this thing that
i've been thinking about it's this kind
of idea of complexity nice and um uh
it's kind of like
and that's that's what that ended up you
planted the seed of complexity to santa
fe that's beautiful it's a beautiful
vision but but i mean so that but what's
happened then is this idea of complexity
and you know ken you know and i started
the first research center at university
of illinois for doing that in the first
journal complex systems and so on and uh
and it's kind of an interesting thing in
in my life at least that it's kind of
like you plant this seed you have this
idea it's a kind of a science idea you
have this idea of sort of focusing on
the phenomenon of complexity the deeper
idea was this computational paradigm but
the the nominal idea is this kind of
idea of complexity okay then you roll
time forward 30 years or whatever 35
years whatever it is um and you say what
happened okay well now there are a
thousand complexity institutes around
the world um i think more or less we've
been trying to count them um and uh you
know there are 40 complexity journals i
think um and so
it's kind of like what actually happened
in this field right and and i look at a
lot of what happened and i'm like
uh you know i have to admit to some eye
rolling so to speak because it's kind of
like like what is what what's what
what's actually going on well what
people definitely got
was this idea of computational models
and then they got but they thought one
of the one of the kind of cognitive
mistakes i think is they say we've got a
computational model
and it
and we're looking at a system that's
complex
and our computational model gives
complexity by goalie that must mean it's
right
and unfortunately because complexity is
a generic phenomenon and computational
irreducibility is a
generic phenomenon that actually tells
you nothing and so then the question is
well what can you do you know there's a
lot of things that have been sort of
done under this banner of complexity and
i think it's been very successful in
providing sort of an interdisciplinary
way of connecting different fields
together which is powerful in itself
right i mean that's a biology in
economics and yeah it is right and it's
a good organizing principle but but in
the end a lot of that is around this
kind of computational paradigm
computational modeling that's the raw
material that powers that kind of uh
that kind of correspondence i think and
the question is sort of what is the you
know i was just thinking recently you
know we've been i mean the the other
we've been we've been
for years people told me you should
start some wolfram institute that does
basic science
you know all i have is a company that
that builds software and we you know we
have a little piece that does basic
science as kind of a hobby people are
saying you should start this wolfram
institute thing and and i've been you
know because i've known about lots of
institutes and i've seen kind of that
flow of money and and kind of you know
what happens in different situations and
so on so i've been kind of reluctant but
uh but i've i've i have realized that
you know what we've done with our
company over the last 35 years you know
we built a very good machine for doing r
d and you know innovating and creating
things and i just applied that machine
to the physics project that's how we did
the physics project in a fairly short
amount of time with a you know
efficient machine with you know various
people involved and so on um and so you
know it works for basic science and it's
like we can do more of this
and so in biology and chemistry so it's
it's become an institute yes well it
needs to become an institution an
official institute right right but the
the thing that so i was thinking about
okay so what do we do with complexity
you know what what there are all these
people who've uh you know what what
should happen to that field yeah and
what i realized is there's kind of this
area of foundations of complexity that's
about these questions about simple
programs what they do that's far away
from a bunch of the detailed
applications that people well it's not
far away it's the it's the under you
know the the bedrock underneath those
applications and so i realized recently
this is my a recent kind of little uh
innovation of a sort um a post that i'll
do very soon
about um
uh kind of you know the foundations of
complexity what really are they i think
they're really two ideas two conceptual
ideas that i hadn't really enunciated i
think before one is what i call
metamodeling the other is ruleology
so what is meta modeling so matter
modeling is you've got this complicated
model and it's a model of you know
hedgehogs interacting with this
interacting with that
and the question is what's really
underneath that what is it you know is
it a turing machine is it a cellular
automaton you know what is the
underlying stuff underneath that model
and so there's this kind of meta science
question of given these models what is
the core model and i realized i mean to
me that's sort of an obvious question
but then i realized i've been doing
language design for 40 years and
language design is exactly that question
you know underneath all of this detailed
stuff people do what are the underlying
primitives and that's a question people
haven't tended to ask about models they
say well we've got this nice model for
this and that and the other what's
really underneath it and what you know
because once you have the thing that's
underneath it well for example this
multi-computation idea is an ultimate
meta modeling idea because it's saying
underneath all these fields is one kind
of paradigmatic structure and you know
you can you can imagine the same kind of
thing and much more sort of uh
much sort of shallower levels in
in in different kinds of modeling so
this the first activity is this kind of
meta modeling the the kind of the the
models about models so to speak you know
what is the what's what's you know
drilling down into models that's one
thing the other thing is this this thing
that i think we're going to call
ruleology which is kind of the the okay
you've got these simple rules you've got
cellular automata you've got turing
machines you've got substitution systems
you've got registered machines got all
these different things what do they
actually do in the wild and this is an
area that i've spent a lot of time you
know working on it's a lot of stuff in
my new kind of science book is about
this um you know this new book i wrote
about combinators is is full of stuff
like this
and and this journal complex systems has
lots of papers about these kinds of
things but but there isn't really a home
for people who do radiology or whatever
as you call the basic science of rules
yes yes right so it's it's like
you've got some what is it is it
mathematics no it isn't really like
mathematics in fact from my now
understanding of meta mathematics i
understand that it's the molecular
dynamics level it's not the level that
mathematicians have traditionally cared
about it's not computer science because
computer science is about writing
programs that do things you know that
were for a purpose not programs in the
wild so to speak it's not physics it
doesn't have anything to do with you
know it may be underneath some physics
but it's not physics as such so it just
hasn't had a home and if you look at you
know but what's great about it is
it's a surviving field so to speak it's
something where you know one of the
things i i find sort of inspiring about
mathematics for example is you look at
mathematics that was done you know in
ancient greece ancient you know babylon
egypt and so on it's still here today
you know you find an icosahedron that
somebody made in ancient egypt you look
at it oh that's a very modern thing it's
an icosahedron you know it's it's a
timeless kind of kind of activity and
this idea of studying simple rules and
what they do it's a timeless activity
and i can see that over the last 40
years or so as you know
even with cellular automata it's kind of
like you know you can sort of catalogue
what what are the different cellular
autonomous are used for and you know
like the the simplest rules like like
one you might even know this one rule
184 it's um rule 184 is a minimal model
for road traffic flow and you know it's
also a minimal model for various other
things but it's kind of fun that you can
literally say you know rule 90 is a
minimal model for this and this and this
rule 4 is a minimal model for this and
it's kind of remarkable that you can
just by in this raw level of this kind
of study of rules
they then branch they're the raw
material that you can use to make models
of different things so it's a it's a
very pure basic science but it's one
that you know people have explored it
but they've been kind of a little bit in
the wilderness and i think you know one
of the things that i would like to do
finally is is uh you know i i always
thought that sort of this notion of pure
and chaos pure and nks being the acronym
for my book new kind of science um was
uh
was something that people should be
doing and and you know we tried to
figure out what's the right
institutional structure to do this stuff
you know we we dealt with a bunch of
universities oh you know can we do this
here well what department would it be in
it well it isn't in a department it's
it's its own new kind of thing that's
why that's why the book was called the
new kind of science um it's kind of the
the because that's an increasingly good
description of what it is so to speak
we're actually we were thinking about
kind of the ruleological society because
we're realizing that it's kind of
it's it's some you know there's a
there's it's very it's very interesting
i mean i've never really done something
like this before because there's this
whole group of researchers who are
who've been doing things that are really
in some cases very elegant very
surviving very solid you know here's
this thing that happens in this very
abstract system
but it's like
it's like what is that part of you know
it's it doesn't have a a home and i
think that's something i you know i kind
of fault myself for not having been more
you know when complexity was developing
in the 80s i didn't understand the the
the danger of applications that is it's
really cool that you can apply this to
economics and you can apply it to
evolutionary biology
and this and that and the other but what
happens with applications is everything
gets sucked into the applications and
the pure stuff it's like the pure
mathematics there isn't any pure
mathematics so to speak it's all just
applications of mathematics and i i
failed to kind of make sure that this
kind of pure area was was kind of um
maintained and and and developed and i
think now you know one of the things i i
want to try to do and and you know it's
a funny thing because i'm used to look
i've been a
tech ceo for more than half my life now
so you know this is what i know how to
do and um you know i can i can make
stuff happen and get projects to happen
even as it turns out basic science
projects in that kind of setting and and
how that translates into kind of uh you
know there are a lot of people working
on for example our physics project sort
of distributed through the academic
world and that's working just great but
the question is you know can we have a
sort of accelerator mechanism that makes
use of kind of what we've learned in in
sort of r d innovation and you know but
on the other hand it's a funny thing
because you know in a company in the end
the thing is you know it's a company it
makes products that sell things sells
things to people um in you know when
you're doing basic research one of the
challenges is there isn't that same kind
of of sort of mechanism and so it's it's
it's you know how do you drive the thing
in a in a kind of a led kind of way so
that it really can can make forward
progress rather than you know what can
often happen in you know in in academic
settings where it's like well there are
all these flowers blooming but it's not
clear that there you know that it's the
yeah they have a central mission and a
drive just like you do with the company
that's delivering a big overarching
product and that's that's uh but the the
challenges you know when you have a
the the the economics of the world are
such that you know when you're
delivering a product and people say well
that's useful we'll buy it
and then that kind of feeds back and
okay then you can then you can pay the
people who build it to eat you know so
they can eat and so on and with basic
science the the payoff
is very much less visible and and you
know with this physics project as i say
the big surprise has been that i mean
you know
for example well the big surprise with
the physics project is that it's looks
like it has near-term applications and i
was like i'm guessing this is 200 years
away
it's um i was kind of using the analogy
of of you know newton
uh starting a satellite launch company
which would have been kind of wrong time
um and uh you know but but it turns out
that's not the case but but we can't
guarantee that and if you say we're
signing up to do basic research basic
ruliology let's say
and you know and we can't we don't know
the horizon you know it's it's an
unknown horizon it's kind of like an
undecidable kind of proposition of when
is this proof going to end so to speak
when is it going to be something that
that
that gets applied
well i i hope this is this becomes a
vibrant new field of radiology i love it
like i told you many many times it's one
of
the most amazing ideas that has been
brought to this world so i hope you
get a bunch of people to explore this
world
thank you once again for spending your
really valuable time with me today sorry
fun stuff thank you
you